Donald Trump was interviewed this
morning on Fox News by brown-nosing
sycophant Maria Bartiromo
she was actually a pretty damn good
financial journalist 20 years ago I used
to watch her when I was getting into
stock trading early in high school and
now she is just a trump suck-up on the
Fox Business Network this interview
aired this morning but it was previously
recorded as I gather and the interview
was an absolutely unmitigated house of
horrors I want to go through some of the
most bizarre and disturbing moments with
you we could spend all day just looking
at this interview but I want to pick
just two important moments of Maria
Bartiromo gave Trump a softball
interview like she always does and yet
Trump is so clueless his ignorant is so
lethally weaponized that even Maria
Bartiromo couldn't save him with
softball questions so let's take a look
now to get this first thing out of the
way the goal posts are again being moved
on the coronavirus death toll now Trump
is talking about we're going to have
more than a hundred thousand deaths and
that is a great victory because of how
much worse it could have been check this
out and look at how casually Trump has
doubled the expected number of deaths
from just three weeks ago and yet it's
still calling it a victory thanks to him
we're gonna lose over a hundred thousand
perhaps in this country now in all
fairness that's at the bottom level of
the scale we would have lost two million
we will lost more if we did it a
different way but you're talking about a
hundred thousand more a little bit less
more who knows it's a terrible thing No
so that can't be replaced
we're spending trillions of dollars on
all of the damage economically
financially that it's caused so it it is
a terrible thing it's just an incredible
thing so he says that's at the bottom we
could have lost more than two million
people so there are two important
takeaways here yesterday we did a
debunking about we're now testing as
much as South Korea per capita important
to understand the the genesis of that
disinformation I want you to now
understand the genesis of this two
million thing that we hear a couple
things that are important to know number
one the goal posts have been moved into
the locker room
they will soon be out in the parking lot
for a month or longer Trump was talking
about we may lose 60,000 people and
that's going to be a really great job
that we'll have done we blew past sixty
thousand deaths so Trump starts talking
about listen we could lose seventy or
eighty thousand people we hit 70 and
Trump started talking about could be
ninety to a hundred thousand now Trump
is cavalierly and casually saying I'm
gonna lose more than a hundred thousand
people and as long as he always predicts
a number slightly larger than what we
have eventually he's going to be right
eventually he will say you know we're
gonna lose 200,000 maybe and we'll get
to 195 and he'll say we stayed under it
forty percent of the country Falls for
it forty percent of the country will
hear this and believe Trump knows what
he's talking about no matter how many
times he shifts the number more
importantly here's what I really want
people to understand this comparison of
the death toll always to 2.2 or 2.5
million the deaths we could have had if
Donald Trump didn't act understand that
two million deaths is if literally
nothing is done now this would be
impossible because governors do excuse
me do things there is not going to be
any scenario where governors were doing
nothing in fact the governors did stuff
before Trump did we saw stay at home
orders and starting to quarantine and
and the like at the state level before
Trump did anything so when Trump says
understand where two million comes from
two million is we have 331 million
people in the country seventy percent of
the country gets the virus that would
get us to hurt immunity if 70 percent
got the virus that means about 230
million people get the virus we expect
an infection fatality rate not a case
fatality rate an infection fatality rate
of about 1% 1% of 231 million is 2.3
million so that is literally no
mitigation so when Trump says listen
we're gonna lose a hundred thousand
instead of two million thanks to me it's
a worthless comparison that says nothing
at all about Donald Trump's response the
important point is we're now at 85,000
deaths were
affected to hit a hundred thousand in
about a week or ten days the numbers
will continue climbing but Trump will
claim victory no matter the death number
because he has set 2.2 2.3 million as
the bar that he is keeping us below next
clip clip of Trump exhibiting such a
poor understanding of trade economics
and manufacturing and foreign policy
that he actually says if we end our
relationship with China
our financial relationship our
relationship of trade we would save five
hundred billion dollars
I'm gonna play the clip Trump seems to
think if we just we stop importing and
exporting with China we quote save 500
billion take a look at this
these pulpit is Xi Jinping I have a very
good relationship but I just right now I
don't want to speak to him because you
know senator cotton was saying maybe we
should be limiting the amount of visas
that we give to students who want to
study things like want there are many
things and AI there are many things we
could do we could do things we could cut
off the whole relationship now if you
did what would happen you'd say 500
billion dollars if you cut off the whole
relationship look at what point does it
and I said this for years I said it with
other countries also you know China's
not the only country ripping us off this
is one of the most incoherent things
that Trump has actually said in his
presidency and I'm gonna explain to you
why first there's this idea that we we
save 500 billion I believe what Trump is
talking about is our trade deficit with
China as recently as a couple of years
ago I had trouble finding the numbers
from from last year but a couple of
years ago we had a five hundred billion
dollar trade deficit with China what
that means is we import 500 billion more
in products from China than we export to
China we have a deficit of 500 billion
dollars so it seems that Trump who has
the economics understanding of a fruit
fly thinks if we cancel all trade we end
up at zeroes meaning the 500 billion
deficit goes away and it's like save
five hundred billion dollars now this is
not how trade and economies work the 500
billion trade deficit with China would
go away if we were to stop all trade
with China maybe it doesn't even really
work that way but then we would have a
massive deficit in terms of the products
that we all take for granted and then
prices would explode on a whole bunch of
stuff because our economy is based on
cheap stuff from China we would have to
there's a couple options if we stopped
trade with China on the one side for
importing we either have to import from
other countries the stuff we get from
China which just shifts the trade
deficit and it would explode demand for
these products in the new countries we
deal with bringing up the prices that
doesn't sound too good for American
businesses and individuals if we decide
to manufacture all of the stuff we get
from China internally I mean it would be
impossible but imagine that we did it
would take years to build those supply
chains but imagine we did it stuff would
cost way way more because the reason we
get these things from China is because
they're cheaper and our economy is based
on that and then you also have to
remember a ton of our businesses would
fail if we stopped exporting to China as
Trump says which would save us 500
billion as he puts it all of these
American businesses that are exporting
to China go under what do you think the
economic impact would be of that on
employment on disposable incomes on the
stock prices as Trump might see it of
these companies this is so absurd and
crazy and it is almost inconceivable
that an American president would have
such a lack of basic economic
understanding and Maria Bartiromo
through no fault of her own she's a
disastrous Trump brown-noser
through no fault of her own she has
exposed Trump in this interview as
completely and utterly clueless not just
on coronavirus we knew that but also
clueless on economics to a degree that
even those of us following this for the
last few years would arguably be stunned
and appalled by no understanding
whatsoever we're gonna have more about
this on the David Pakman show Instagram
that's david pakman show on instagram
also on my personal Instagram
it is planting day today we are past the
frost here in Boston follow me at David
Pakman on Instagram to follow the urban
gardening adventure a lot happening
there in the next 24 hours check this
out the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a premium membership to
Skillshare for two months completely
free skill shares the online learning
community with thousands of classes on
almost anything you can imagine always
taught by experts they have classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video